das hat aber jetzt auch wirklich lange
genug gedauert das allererste moleküle
des universums wurde jetzt endlich
gefunden
die erste chemische verbindung quasi
überhaupt der anfang der chemie ohne
dieses molekül gäbe es kein chemie
unterricht und nicht nur weil es dann
keine chemie gäbe sondern weil auch wir
nicht existieren würden es ist der
beginn von allem und er wurde jetzt
gefunden eine sensation klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen was ist wenn man
weiß dass ist existieren muss aber es
einfach nicht zu entdecken ist für
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
eine horrorvorstellung die suche nimmt
kein ende
aber auch die ungewissheit haben wir uns
geirrt gibt es einen denkfehler ist
alles ganz anders als gedacht so oder so
ähnlich ging es der wissenschaft mit dem
ersten molekül der ersten chemischen
verbindung zwischen zwei element nein
ich musste sie irgendwo da draußen sein
aber irgendwie war sie nicht zu finden
rolf güsten vom max planck institut für
radioastronomie in bonn dazu die chemie
im universum begann mit helium zu dritt
das fehlen eines nachweises dieses
moleküls im interstellaren raum hat die
astronomie seit langem vor einem dilemma
gestellt aber wie findet man ein solches
moleküle im weltall dazu haben robert
bunsen und gustav kurs mitte des 19
jahrhunderts also 1800 und die
spektralanalyse erfunden im spektrum des
lichts das von nebeln oder sternen
abgegeben wird gibt es nämlich
unregelmäßigkeit nun mit ihnen kann man
elemente oder eben helium hattrick
finden denn die atome interagieren mit
licht und veränderndes helium tritt war
das erste molekül im universum helium
für dritt- oder h+ nach dem urknall
bildeten sich zunächst als die
temperatur auf 4000 kelvin viel helium
atome und diese reagierten dann mit
wasserstoff atomen die allerdings nur
aus einem proton damals bestanden das
elektron fehlte noch deswegen auch das
haar plus in der formel schon 1925
gelangen ist diese verbindung im labor
herzustellen aber da wo sie eigentlich
sein sollte war sie einfach nicht
aufzufinden und das liegt am licht das
von diesem molekül abgegeben wird es hat
eine frequenz von 2 terahertz und
entspricht damit einer wellenlänge von
0,14 9 mm und das ist ziemlich schlecht
die erdatmosphäre schluckt diesem
wellenlängenbereich komplett sprich mit
teleskopen hier auf der erde ist die
suche nach helium hydrid aussichtslos
deshalb muss aus dem weltraum oder mit
hochfliegenden observatorien gesucht
werden und genau das hat das
forschungsteam gemacht sie haben das
fliegende observatorium sofia eingesetzt
in einer flughöhe von 13 bis 14
kilometern operiert sofia oberhalb der
absorbierenden schichten der unteren
atmosphäre
zitat mit den jüngsten fortschritten in
der terahertz technologie ist es nun
möglich hochauflösende spektroskopie bei
den erforderlichen fernen infraroten
wellenlängen durchzuführen erklärt rolf
güsten sofia befindet sich an bord einer
umgebauten boeing 747 und hat aus dieser
höhe den planetarischen nebel ngc 7027
unter die lupe genommen und wurde jetzt
finde ich das erste molekül des
universums eine absolute sensation jetzt
kann sich die astrophysik viel besser
mit der frühphase des universums uns
insbesondere den chemischen reaktionen
damals dort beschäftigen
chemische bindungen einfach erklärt
x-men cooles video von brings
draufklicken anschauen und auf jeden
fall bei trainings abonnieren bis dann
bleibt